I don't I don't really know what's a and
I don't often think about that sort of
stuff it's cohesion today the try guys
are teaming up with the Hollywood medium
Tyler Henry he's in HoN even just a
regular medium like celebrities go to
him which he means I guess he's better
do you know our names
okay if I hello this might be a hard one
there's been hundreds and hundreds of
years of people claiming they can talk
to the dead there is no one actual
physical piece of proof so when I go to
my readings I never know who I'm reading
or where I'm going and I really
appreciate that because it makes sure
that there's no bias going into reading
and allows for specific details to come
through the try guys are talking to dead
people
not know
[Music]
my job is to do the majority of the
talking don't try to give me a whole
bunch of stories or you know additional
information all just kind of scribbles
it just kind of helps me tune out and
kind of ignore the fact that there's a
bunch of cameras rolling we got a lot of
them
you guys know confirmation biases like
if I go in thinking this guy can talk to
dead people
the one thing that is like a little bit
closed I'll be like yes yes Tyler oh my
god you're psychic
what do you see can you get a Social
Security number
yep phone number lottery numbers those
be great I immediately person if I sit
around long enough I'll start getting
sensations visuals sometimes an audible
voice sometimes the smell sometimes a
taste but I have to put all of these
impressions into coherent messages I
mean I want to believe in it I like
Harry Potter as much as the next guy
oftentimes if you've seen the show you
know that I work with an object an
object can help make them work direct
connection to a loved one but anybody
can come through from an object so do
you guys have any for me to hold on to
today yeah we each have well we have a
couple objects I don't know how many
objects is too many objects no such
thing no good never as many as we'd like
so I feel like I'll start with this
gravy on mine and we'll sure see what
comes in so let me see I'm just gonna
take one sec to
[Music]
okay I'm gonna try and feel some
presences right now
yeah I'm just tickling ghost balls so
what I'm doing a reading is you'll see I
scribble and the reason that this
happens for me is it's a way of kind of
quieting my mind and almost distracting
myself from my environment and sure
enough it just seems to kind of be my
way of distracting myself enough to
unlock I think the part of my brain that
might be more subconscious but that's
basically how it works
my sister insisted that while we had you
here I also gave you this cat toy that's
some sweet okay all on the cat toy we'll
see what comes we'll see what happens
you know what happened but we'll stay
with transpires do they they do they're
not like no it definitely isn't that way
but they can come through as an energy I
believe anything with sentience does
continue on in some capacity the bonds
we make in life continue on to some
extent this is the most exciting yes I
know I just keep saying you know Salem
from Sabrina the Teenage Witch that
black cat with the eyes they keep
showing me this symbolically eating a
black cat what is the business yes yes
that's literally all I'm saying yeah he
doesn't he doesn't have a lot to say I
guess I'm not sure but makes sense that
even an afterlife cats are not gonna
give you what you want
that is totally fulfilling for me thank
you
how tough is dating I went on a date we
were sitting across eating our ramen and
as I'm sitting there I was like look I
can't continue this date until I tell
you what's coming through and you know
he knew it was a medium gonna see your
grandmother's coming through and she
relayed all these messages burst his
ears super overwhelmed I was like great
now we can finish our ramen and we can
continue our game they're having me
bring out this feeling of like
filtration system liver kidney pancreas
that area and I feel like I'm a little
little concerned there about this do you
know of any when dealing with any
filtration issues I do drink heavily
even though I'm probably the least
skeptical out of the four of us about
mediums
I actually am only one who has not known
anyone who's passed personally a little
over a year ago I lost my grandmother
Evelyn is her name was her name
my fiancee Becky her grandfather passed
away about six months ago I would really
want to talk to my grandfather
we called him nanu he died when I was in
middle school about eight years before
my grandmother passed she had an
accident that was unfortunately the
beginning of a slow end she was always
incredibly nice to me he was not like
super great at being mobile right he was
old we planned our wedding to be in a
location that was within 15 minutes of
where her grandparents lived because he
can only travel so far it was incredibly
important to Becky and myself that he'd
be there for the wedding and
unfortunately you know that that's not
the case when I would go to visit her it
felt like it gave her anxiety but I
think if I'm being honest I think it was
hard for me to be there and so I didn't
really get to say goodbye to her not
ever
it's something that I feel guilty about
a lot of my outlook on life was shaped
by him he was a very kind caring person
had a very pragmatic approach to life
and he always told me that you can do
anything you put your mind to so long as
you work hard I was really moved by his
passing and I would love to talk to him
again there have to be talking about a
baby Wow careful's I'm sorry do it in
your case did you know of anyone within
family think brother brothers there's
basically a situation or there's gonna
be a baby that's gonna be born I don't
know if this has already happened you're
gonna end up having a niece or there's
gonna end up being a connection with the
niece and around this nice there's going
to be some issues academically or like
around the way of verbalize the way I
talk the way I
I process it's not a bad thing she grows
out of this I don't know when that's
gonna make sense or how that's gonna
fall into place but it would be brother
and this daughter dealing with some just
development tulip stuff
they outgrow it it seems fine it's just
good to keep in mind yeah that's all
that's how it is really yeah whoo my
niece Alex is maybe a little bit behind
right we're not super concerned about it
but they know that it's something that
thinks any parent couple is going to be
focused on of course the best for your
kids
absolutely yeah and oftentimes details
like that will come between readings
because it's not just your reading it's
reading for the whole family so it was a
feeling of letting him know that she's
gonna be okay
watching over her and there's a very
special connection there I'm happy
talking about sister or female I have
two sisters
you can't they're putting children
around one and not children around the
other but how does that work so I said
no children on either side okay is one
thinking getting pregnant is one like
more the one to get pregnant let me tell
you how wrong he is about that you think
I don't like babies I texted my sisters
right after the reading and said hey so
I had this really amazing reading Tyler
Henry's really awesome he basically said
that one of you is going to probably
have babies hmm weird since kids this is
how much my sister's hate babies sorry
yang dynasty how do we talk about
I think wife hey every talk about career
they're having me talk about their
having talked about anaesthetic they're
referring to her and her sister I don't
know if sister and she will work
together or work beside one another I
don't know what this is
oh they're having me acknowledged
entreprenurial around this and then I
feel like your wife might have some
entrepreneurial opportunities but I'm
seeing sister her career I'm bunching it
together and then I'm separating it and
then I'm seeing her doing like her own
thing and it's like it keeps coming in
so might said absolutely not what what
does your wife do and what does her
sister do my wife and my her sister
owned a business
okay and actually her her sister's going
off to grad school and just sort of
they're totally sweat changing it up
awesome well I wanted oh that's great
and that's that like looks like a good
thing of the way is this coming because
I'm seeing them parting ways but I've
seen working together and then I feel
like we see going on individually and I
feel like she needs to know that she's
making the right choice my parents sent
the dress that she were to their wedding
okay so I have to feel like I have to
highlight this woman that I have to
bring up no I'm just having me highlight
ee-ee-ee-ee
over and over and over again just give
me the yes or the no do you have a
female with an e name in your family
who's passed away yes okay would this be
on the grandparent level she's having me
acknowledge dealing with some difficulty
breathing and this was kind of coming in
as like I was dealing with some lung
problems and there may have been kind of
a I don't say traumatizing situation but
it's a situation that seems kind of hard
to watch where I feel like I'm kind of
struggling and I don't I'm very clearly
unhappy with the fact that I'm being
kept alive with this oxygen thing or
with the breathing thing and she just
like let me go let me go she was
connected to a respirator she had you
know tubes going up her nose that helped
her breathe whenever I would visit her
the first thing she would do is she
would try and take out the breathing
tube and she would try and get up from
the chair it's like when she was having
time with you she wanted to set time
with you and didn't want this this thing
it just seems almost like I'm sorry had
to see this and I'm sorry she felt that
way it's a common thing and then that
way I think it's important we the fact
you know that that there should be no
guilt for the fact that maybe you didn't
visit as much as you could have because
they she didn't want you to have to see
her in that way yes
no that's that's good to hear admit it
for what it's worth and she's here now I
like my fondest memories of her are from
my childhood
absolutely it's important the people who
live these lives don't want their entire
lives defined by how they died and I
think if anything this work kind of
shows that that people bring up the best
parts of their lives and the people they
care about and people they love not
always just focusing on their death okay
so let me see here they're good they're
having me talk about your dad and
they're having he's still living correct
yes everybody talked about him just good
to keep in mind he has a susceptibility
to sleep apnea so just tell them okay
that's sort of the thing right it's you
have to be more open to believing it to
be able to talk to someone in another
place haven't you talked about elderly
so he's your grandmother passed away yes
my grandmother's passed away the thing
is that this men typically die first is
there a case where the woman woman
actually transitions and then she leaves
a man behind who's still living okay
so father has a sister right the way
this is coming in is they're putting
sister and grandpa together she also has
another man they haven't me talk about
Jay Jay Jay so Jay check and see if
there's like a Jer to having me talk
about like looking at the heart getting
hard checked I think people get older it
happens but there's a feeling of either
a switch and medication taking one
medication and then either pausing this
maybe looking at something else I
assumed this if your grandmother is
connecting to him and he's still alive
say that's awesome my aunt is with a man
named Gary and he recently changed his
medication and they've been monitoring
his heart I don't really know Gary that
well I don't know anything about his
health I don't know anything about his
medications so when I asked my aunt
about this he says yeah we did all of
that that is all incredibly pertinent to
right now it's just crazy how do you get
this information do you have a
grandfather that's passed on your mom
said a family yes okay and digit passed
away of cancer or did he have cancer
yeah okay he is having me acknowledge a
reference to a feeling of I'm singing
ornaments and for some reason your
grandfather's having me highlight
Christmas time Christmas time Christmas
time the way it was coming through the
thing is is there would have been an
instance in which I feel like when I'm
in the hospital there's a feeling with
this a being insistent of coming home or
an assistant of this I know there's
nothing that can be done for me so I
need to be in my familiar space
I keep seeing celebrating Christmas
celebrating Christmas celebrating
Christmas so if someone is sick in a
room and they still decorate it or they
still get a Christmas tree or they put a
string of lights there's a feeling of
appreciation around this for like thank
you for doing this but hey because the
filling is though I'm sick there's a
feeling of still being festive and
that's the way that I would describe it
when did he pass away 2001 do you know
what month it was in January
okay so he would have just gotten
through the holidays then basically
before passing away I'm very excited to
see if you can even reach anyone that
I'm related to because everyone who has
passed like my grandparents all died in
Korea during the war do my ancestors
like speak to him in Korean and he's
just like at like a Korean restaurant
going like I don't know what they're
saying but like I think they want you to
order the soup I rely on visuals so
visuals are universal if I say heart
whether someone spoke Chinese or English
it means the same thing to me this is
good to keep in mind for you this is
gonna sound weird you have some
situations within family and this is
gonna sound so weak so no we didn't
really discuss that there were any
deceased people but there are an uncanny
amount what Tyler said about my mom has
been a family secret for generations
I had just personally learned about it
on camera while we filmed the try guys
father at Series why did you wait so
long oh oh no I did not know that mm-hmm
am I supposed to be finding all this out
from camera okay yeah you can always
include what you wanted in it all I can
say on camera is I totally validate
everything you just said and again it's
one of those things that bring I
probably can't discuss like everything
is like all that is happening it's all
spot-on much of what he said about my
mother in particular were pretty true
we barely been talked about on the phone
let alone in videos and if you've seen
the try guys fatherhood series he's not
very open about stuff connected to any
of these objects I want to give you guys
the opportunity if there's any questions
that your family might have for any of
the people that we've connected with I
can't always say can't get an answer but
sometimes it can help bring forward a
piece of information are there anything
that you can think of so these clothes
actually belong to who would have been
my grandfather in law before he passed
away
Wow he was incredibly close with my
fiancee right so it was just really hard
to lose him for a week married
I know it's very important to her yeah
absolutely I'm so sorry to hear that
let me see if I can connect it all go
from there
so I always say I can't dial direct I
can't make up first and come through I
can't will a person to come through but
there are instances in which people will
kind of come through repeatedly do you
have the two brothers in his family
about brothers no no that's do you know
if he had any siblings for example I I
think he did okay connected on that side
it's kind of like reading a person
through person oh yeah my best with this
there haven't we talked about connected
to him they're bringing me to family
line and then I actually haven't we
talked about an individual and the brain
made of pulmonary and I feel like I have
to go to chest with this this is coming
in I'm kind of going to like what looks
like pulmonary and fluid but check up on
that because there's a reference to two
brothers is coming in and I think it
would be connected like to that and the
way that it's coming through that's so
weird there's also a situation where
someone shouldn't have died and should
have been able to get this treatment and
the feeling is like we're gonna be fine
and then this just kind of comes out of
nowhere and then we we we pass away what
is this I don't I mean I know that just
for him that he had cancer
then it was gone and then write him back
sort of thing when I came back very fast
very quick and sort of ended things a
lot faster than they thought that so was
his original cancer something it was
kind of like more long-term and then
this second cancer came in and how long
how quickly did it pass the second when
he came back through I think it was a
matter of months when they would
reappear and then it went no I said I
know it started it was in his chest and
then it started to spread their analysis
I'm so sorry I couldn't actually confirm
a lot of what Tyler was saying about
Becky's grandpa and his family just
because I didn't get to know him as well
as I wish I could have at least
something came through which is you know
amazing to me because you know he's like
also with me too which is like crazy so
it's just like super overwhelming
sister sister sister sister
they're having me talk about sister I
feel like I have to talk about her
career and then I feel like there's a
feeling of reassurance in the way this
is coming across but we have to talk
about sister sister sister sister sister
sister sister keeps coming in so do you
have a sister I do I can't you only have
one sister yeah that helps sister sister
career and there's a feeling of like
still trying to figure it out and I know
that's odd I don't know why this is
coming in but I feel like there's gonna
be things like they're showing me things
falling into place they're putting this
around her but it's almost a feeling of
like if someone's gonna take a little
longer to get to a point within career
where they feel I'm going to her this is
where I want to be the feeling is like
keep with it but they're keeping either
having me acknowledge her and just kind
of watching over her in a way that's
almost like they're not worried about
you and I don't want to say they're
worried about her but they're kind of
like okay we need to kind of just like
keep her in mind and and help her and
they're heavy talk about emotional
states and just wanting to make sure
that that's all good do you know why
they be emphasizing that so much last
night I had a very emotional
conversation with my sister where she
was she's staying with me right now
she's like sleeping on the couch because
she's kind of in between these two
places Hawaii where she lives in LA
where she comes along for work I need
you to know from that perspective the
way this comes through is they're not
worried about you there knowing what
she's going through and she's gonna be
okay and if there's any message you can
really take with you today like let her
know she's going to be okay they're with
her they're not worried about you if
anything they're excited about you about
all of what you have coming it's like we
were just talking about how she was
struggling
and the thought that all of my relatives
were watching over her
was such a nice feeling just be nice to
to think about your special people in
your life that have died that are still
with you
it's just it's just nice to know that
people watch you wouldn't take care like
how do you pinpoint these things how do
you get this information for me it's so
weird that these consciousnesses are
tapped into all of our lives there's
absolutely no doubting that Tyler has a
gift and that gift helps people what his
gift is you can debate on your own I'm
here telling you that I believe in this
guy [ __ ] I believe that's crazy I don't
even know if I believe in God but I
believe in Tyler Henry what a crazy
[ __ ] thing it was maybe the most
confusing and surreal thing I've ever
done and I've met Lance Bass if what
he's doing isn't hurt anyone then like
who the [ __ ] cares
same thing with religion same thing with
spiritual belief like everyone's just
trying to find an answer and maybe it
comes in the form of having a special
gift and helping people at 101 mediums
can be a very controversial idea for a
lot of people I think having a
first-hand experience can be essential
to really understand it but I hope that
if anybody gets anything out of this
whether they're watching the show well
they would medium or watching readings
like this that people see celebrity or
not that there's very special
connections that can be made validations
that show that we're all connected to
each other that's important
whether they're alive or they've passed
away just surround yourself with
relevant people and hold them close my
ancestors don't look like the ones in
the wand
oh definitely not damn I wanted him to
just like turn it'd be like great stone
dragon have you awakened man I would
have [ __ ] came in my pants if he had
said that I'm the great stone dragon I
would make a great medium
[Laughter]